الاصرار الروسيه على اخضع بلده فوليدار
الصغيره الواقعه شمال شرقي اوكرانيا اثار
تساؤلات حول اهميه هذه المدينه فسوليدار
اصغر من
باخمود بحوالي ثلاث مرات ولا يتجاوز عدد
السكان فيها ال10 الاف نسمه الى ان مغريات
عده تقف خلف تماسك روسيا بها اولها يتمثل
بكون بخموت محطه وصول بكون هذه المدينه
وحطت وصول الى باخمن التي تبعد 15 كلم
عنها تلالها المرتفعه تعطيها ميزه الاشراف
على خطوط الامداد الاستراتيجيه بين منطقتي
لوغانسك ودنياسك في اقليم
يصبح تطبيق من الشمال اسهل بكثير وبالتالي
تعطيل خطوط الامداد والتواصل الاوكرانيه
هذا بدوره من شانه ان يخرج خط الدفاع
الرئيسي اوكرانيا في دومباس يفتح الطريق
امام تقدم روسي في مدن رئيسيه كبرى جنوب
مقاطعه دنيا مثل الكراماتوس وسلوفيانس كما
ان ارتياح القوات الروسيه في المحور
الشمالي يجعل للعوده نحو لمان وكوبيانس في
المثلث الساخن حول طريق الزفاتف اسباطوفو
بين مقاطعه حركاب ودنياسك ورمان ممكنا سبب
اخر مشاهدينا جعل من سوليدار محطه انظار
الروس وفقره رئيس مجموعه فاجنر وهو
احتوائها لانفاق تعدين ممتده تحت الارض
هذه الانفاق تمتد الى اكثر من 100 و60 كلم
قادر على اتساعه جنود ودبابات وعربات
موشات قتاليه مع قدرتها على التحرك فيها
بحريه ومن ضمن المقام مع الروسيه في
سوليدار السيطره على مناجم الملح الكبيره
في هذه المنطقه